[Musique]
donc cet après midi c'est la première
fois que je tourne skyrock dans les
locaux de skyrock et du coup je vais
tourner mon arrivée dans les studios
après le cristal au téléphone c'était
c'était génial estime le tournage chez
skyrock on a été hyper bien accueilli
puis c'est d'autant plus qu'ils font que
qui avait très envie qu'on tourne chez
eux aussi étaient assez fou parce que
tout le monde avait envie de montrer de
quoi il est capable et en tant que
rappeur et en tant qu'animateur donc on
a eu un frère de sky qui était le
parfait chef d'orchestre des scènes
qu'on tournait dans ce plat naîtra un
vrai rôle de composition le mien voilà
en effet c'était top
on était sûr bon moi j'ai connu les
les ambiances de justement de planète
rap de skyrock
il ya plein de monde j'ai retrouvé la
même les mêmes ambiances un peu familier
je reste un peu l'ambiance quartier on
est tous ensemble ça rigole ça va ça
fumait sa buvait sa déconner c'est un
super super super bon et c'est tout et
qu'un premier coup de fil qui ne
viennent pas alors au fret je suis à
l'antenne en temps direct comment tu
t'appelles tu m'appelles clément en tant
que rappeur moi j'aime bien skyrock
forcément ça en présente un certain
accomplissement pour un rappeur petit
navire est fatigué je crois que tu te
fais trop vieux n'oublie pas d'être très
sympa là ce qui va marquer la rupture de
contrat concept du rap voulu répondre
n'hésite pas si vous répondra que je
connais c'est le rap game c'est ça que
j'aime dans deux émissions justement
près c'est c'est super intéressant à
jouer
mais en même temps c'est complexe parce
que justement il faut passer justement
dans un moment super à l'aise tu es là
tu étais on va dire c'est les lumières
sont sur toi à un mec qui arrive est
justement le temps toutes leurs soirées
nationale ou que je ne comprends pas ce
qui se passe mais en même temps énervé
mais en même temps sont menacés et en
fait il ya tout ça a joué
[Musique]
tellement au moment où il rentre oui
rentrer dans les studios de skyrock
finalement et qui rencontrent ma star il
et les cram un gamin je veux jouer ça le
gars qui a impressionné parce qu'ils
voient ce rapport préféré autant apg
n'est pas ce qu'il veut envoyer des
punchline en pleine tronche et en même
temps il a envie de bien faire donc il
est aussi concentrée sur ce qui doit
rappeler c'est assez complexe mais ces
colis et réalise pas qu'en fait ce qu'il
vient de faire
c'est pas juste un moyen d'ouvrir la
porte ça a été aussi perçue comme une
attaque personnelle au sort si quelqu'un
qui connaît la musique surtout quand ils
voient freestyle et à skyrock et y
ajouter près son mode qu'est ce qui se
passe en fait parce qu'il sait qu'il est
bon et c'est ça qui va faire qu'il va
emmener tout ce truc de 2,2 de deux
rivales et ample de ce qui fallait à ce
moment là c'était de montrer aux
spectateurs que ce mec-là qui est deux
minutes à vendre de la weed va être un
phénomène et va être le héros de cette
série d'événements
on avait conscience pendant qu'on
tournait que c'était fort qu'il était
habité et qu'il était habité par apache
et pas par atik ce jour là il fait
quelque chose qui est essentielle pour
la série voilà c'est un acteur ce jour
là c'est un acteur qui rappe mais qui
ira pas un personnage qui rappelle lui
quoi
[Musique]
g il faut que la prison pour lui
kitambala vague d une création originale
à découvrir en avant-première en ce
moment sur my canal